hey leute und willkommen zu einer
weiteren zieht vorstellung heute stelle
ich euch den zieht von killer chris bzw
christoph vor der mir diesen sieg per
e-mail gesendet hat seinen minecraft
name ist killer chris und den würde ich
auch gerne anziehen also sein skin
allerdings spielt einerseits das
programm gerade rum und andererseits
auch die mojang server also das ist ja
gerade alles ein bisschen problematisch
bei denen deswegen sich einfach meinen
eigenen kindern aber ich glaube das
sollte euch nicht stören
der cee'd ist dieser hier also den seht
ihr dort eingeblendet ich mache nur ich
habe gar nicht mehr im speicher na ja
der ist auf jeden fall 580 also 580 15
14 mal die 18 01 80 50 also sowieso eine
telefonnummer
das hat vor und zwar ist nix am spot
jetzt einfach nur so ein cooles berge
wie ich finde
hier ist eine bucht von einem dschungel
der auch anfängt da in die richtung
ungefähr
aber wir fliegen in ein paar koordinaten
und zwar meinte der christoph zu mir
dass man ein npc dorf findet was halb im
wasser steht und in dem npc dort findet
man in der schmiede auch noch ganz
interessante sache
ich weiß natürlich schon was allerdings
lasse ich dann ein bisschen spannend
wird das wird euch auf jeden fall freuen
was da drin ist und wir müssen zu den
koordinaten iks gleich 200 bzw
y gleich 700 fliegen das heißt also
nicht exil on 700 106 700 x2 265 sollte
das dorf schon sehen kann man schon
wieder weg machen
genau hier ist nämlich das dorf und zwar
kommt hier ein fluss rhein und der geht
mündet in einen see hier sage ich mal so
in einen tiefen see und hier ist halt
ein relativ großes npc doch was halt
halt mit halb im wasser steht was ich
ganz interessant finde habe ich noch nie
gesehen
deswegen wollte ich euch das einfach mal
vorstellen als wären wir halt ganz
normal immer die räume von den leuten
und jetzt kommen wir zur schmiede und
zwar in den öfen ist glaube ich nie was
drin bei spielen habe ich bin mir gar
nicht so sicher
aber hier in der kiste habt ihr ein 11
obsidian der rest ist normal und das 11
obsidian ist ganz cool weil damit könnt
ihr euch wenn ihr euch geschickt
anstellt was ich gerade nicht benannt
ich mache was mir hier das ist ein
normales portal das sat 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10
das heißt ihr habt danach sogar noch
einen obsidian übrig den ihr dann unter
anderem für den tschad mit table oder so
benutzen könnt oder so gemacht du stets
voll ihrem video processing auch das
will ich nicht also damit könnt ihr euch
halt direkt zum portal machen und
außerdem sind darin halt auch noch zwei
eisernen apfel zwei brötchen und ein
helm den schmerz war ganz kurz ihre
wunderschöne aus wunderschön dich euro
belaufen
so das war's eigentlich von diesem zieht
das einzige interessante an diesem zieht
ist ganz einfach dass ihr mitten in
seinem dschungel biom was allgemein
ziemlich flaches wasser hat auf einmal
so einen npc dorf steht und was das ist
weiß ich auch nicht
und da steht halb im wasser was ich halt
noch nie gesehen aber das wollte ich
einfach nur mal ganz kurz zeigen wenn
ihr das video gut vereine
beziehungsweise den cee'd gut fand gibt
dem video einen daumen hoch und wenn
jetzt nicht so gut findet wir sehen
welche kritik habt einfach und daumen
runter geben
und wie immer sleeps und skins von euch
in die kommentare schreiben die dann
vielleicht erst mal benutzen werden wir
sehen beim nächsten mal schau